ich bin total gegen ungerechtigkeiten
ich möchte die welt ein bisschen schöner
machen wirklich gerechtigkeit bringen
und da helfen wo andere wirklich nicht
mehr weiterkommen das kommt von mir
wirklich vom herzen
der heutige hilferuf führt frank ochse
nach dem berg einem 390 seelen dorf in
brandenburg bei diesen traurigen fall
ist besonderes fingerspitzengefühl
gefragt ich treffe gleich die
alleinerziehende mutter kathrin
gierschner sie hat durch einen unfall
ihren partner verloren
doch statt trauern zu können hat sie es
mächtig ärger mit der krankenkasse in
diesem einfamilienhaus wohnt kathrin
gärtner mit ihren beiden töchtern der
elf monate alten charlotte der
vierjährigen luise und ihrem freund
mario doch am 30 april zerbricht die
familien idylle von einem tag auf den
anderen mann kam nach hause und hat
gesagt er komplett wieder her will nur
noch zwei sachen erledigen nun kehrte
nach klosterheide und währenddessen hat
er gesagt okay bis gleich wir sehen uns
dann gleich ich hatte guten vorbereitet
wir haben schon angefangen kaffee zu
trinken und ich dachte mir okay er kommt
einfach ein bisschen später und sodann
sie gegen 16 uhr und ich bekam einen
anruf vom in dschidda eltern mir wurde
gesagt es gab einen unfall bei dem mario
neumann verunfallt ist der 39 jährige
wurde an einem bahnübergang mit seinem
kleintransporter von einem zug erfasst
und mehrere meter mitgeschleift
ich wusste bis dato noch nicht so
wirklich was passiert ist nun das ist
eine reanimation gehabt ich bin selber
krankenschwester eine rettungsstelle ich
weiß sozusagen den konsequenzen
anzufangen ich wusste sofort was es
bedeutet wenn jemand reanimiert wird
innerhalb von zehn minuten innerhalb von
20 minuten und mir war klar es wird
nicht gut ausgehen
14 jahre waren kathrin und mario ein
paar geheiratet haben sie nie nach dem
tragischen unfall muss die 38-jährige
jetzt allein für ihre töchter sorgen
warum mario von dem zug erfasst wurde
ist bis heute unklar
er kann nur sagen
das ist an dem tag eine dame gab die
ihnen im leben gekommen ist und die ist
schon knapp an diesem bahnübergang oder
an diesem zug vorbei gefahren und er
auch und erst dann auch hinterher
sozusagen und ist ungebremst in den zug
gefahren als er wurde insgesamt konnte
man rekonstruieren 20 minuten reanimiert
und das hat sozusagen zur folge dass er
am samstagnachmittag um 15 42 an einem
reese passablen nun schon gestorben ist
ich habe deinen um 14 uhr 30 einen anruf
bekommen ich sofort ins krankenhaus
kommen und ich bin durch klinikum
gelaufen wirklich gerannt um nicht zu
spät zu kommen und dachte laufe auflauf
und kommen nicht zu spät jedes mal wenn
ich ihn gesehen habe habe ich mich
bedankt für die schöne zeit für die
kinder
und als wir dann allein über an beide
habe ich mich dann auf ihn drauf gelegt
damit der hand genommen die aus einem
brust gelegt wo wenn herz ich habe
seinen klicken gehört der monitor
gesehen sie hat weniger wurde hat mir
aber kleides vorbei
o
[Musik]
am zweiten mai stirbt katrins man in
ihren armen
bis heute hat sie seinen tod noch nicht
verkraftet
denken immer dass jeden moment um die
ecke kommt und alles wieder so ist wieso
aber mein kopf sagt nehmt das wird nicht
so sein und er kommt nicht um die ecke
und verlässt die sachen noch ein
bisschen menschen oft gehe ich an den
schreibtisch und streicheln die jacke
und denke so ok ich hoffe du hast es
gesehen und oben auf seiner wolke
ich konnte nicht einfach abhauen aber es
war halt der größte wunsch sofort an die
ostsee zu fahren mich dorthin zu setzen
in den schrank und einfach zu weinen und
mich nicht sozusagen mit sachen zu
beschäftigen
die unnötig sind in meinen augen also
zum beispiel irgendwelche banken
irgendwelche gelder sondern einfach nur
zum weinen wenn ich sein möchte und bis
zu wissen wenn die kinder sind gut
versorgt denn kathrin muss marius
baufirma abwickeln zeit zum trauern hat
sie nicht tochter luise denkt täglich an
ihren papa
[Musik]
das war der kathrin beantragt eine
mutter kind kur
diese wird jedoch von der krankenkasse
abgelehnt dann bereits 2018 war sie
wegen ihrer neurodermitis in chur
die zweifache mutter ist verzweifelt
eines abends ins bett gegangen mit lisa
papa zählt traurig gemacht
also mein betten abgebaut und wirst du
nicht mehr weiter kommentieren auch mit
google schreibt die bild zeitung es kann
nicht wahr sein dass uns niemand hilft
dieser traurigen geschichte nichts neben
eine kur aus bringt die erste
mitarbeiterin von hampel tapete bei mir
angerufen hat gesagt wir sind dabei
kämpfen für sie
[Musik]
zwei tage später hatte ich im brief im
briefkasten
es wurde eine kuh genehmigt doch mit der
angebotenen klinik ist kathrin nicht
einverstanden denn die ist auf
neurodermitis nicht auf trauerarbeit
spezialisiert deshalb wendet sie sich
erneut per mail ein bild ich wünsche mir
dass wir jetzt gemeinsam schaffen eine
passende kureinrichtung vorn zu finden
dass das nicht ewig dauert noch also was
nicht noch drei wochen vier wochen fünf
wochen sondern dass es bald losgeht dass
sie endlich zur ruhe kommen können und
dass sie endlich anfangen können für uns
daran zu arbeiten
nach diesem verlauf steht für frank
ochse sofort fest hier muss er direkt
vor ort helfen
ihre mail hat uns wirklich sehr bewegt
vielleicht kann ich heute was für sie
tun kann
franco will unbedingt mehr über katrins
tragisches schicksal erfahren wie geht
es ihnen denn so mit der situation
schlecht sehr schlecht
zum einen ist es ja so dass die sagt 9
14 jahre zusammen und ich denke dass in
der heutigen zeit 14 jahre schon eine
ganze latte an zeit und wir haben zwei
kleine kinder zusammen die auch wohl
gewollt worden sind und waren absolute
wunschkinder und zum anderen fehlt halt
der partner in der eu wo wir in beide
fest im leben gestanden haben und jetzt
wollen sie vernünftig trauer sie wollen
dort dass es ihrer familie wieder besser
geht und jetzt ärgern sie sich über ihre
krankenkasse
also wir möchten ja gerne zur kur fahren
und habe meine nachbarn angerufen habe
gefragt gleich nach dem unfall ob es
möglich ist so gut zu fahren
er hat das recht milliarden hat gesagt
ja ich würde alle notwendigen unterlagen
aus und hat es auch ausgefüllt und ich
hab's dann zur krankenkasse brachten
daraufhin wurde die erste kusche mal
abgelehnt weil die 2018 bereits gefahren
sind
die steht tatsächlich der mdk also der
medizinische dienst kommt zu dem schluss
dass die voraussetzungen für eine mutter
kind der nicht vorliegen
ich halte das für wahnsinn wir sehen
einmal hier die person die dringend
hilfe braucht und einmal so einen
formbrief ist vielleicht war sogar
wirklich einen textbaustein und dass die
kur abgelehnt wird und ich mache das
wirklich genauso fassungslos also da
musste ich einfach helfen und wie war
das als sie das gelesen haben
enttäuschend das war sehr enttäuschend
ich habe sehr aufgemacht und dachte ja
es kann nicht wahr sein jetzt muss man
da auch noch für kämpfen obwohl man
schon keine kraft mehr hat irgendwie das
macht mich wirklich auch fassungslos
also da wird ihnen wirklich ganz übel
mitgespielt sie sind kunden der
techniker krankenkasse und sie so ab zu
bürsten finde ich wirklich unfassbaren
wirklich sprachlos
also da müssen wir gleich mal
telefonieren also da müssen wir für sie
kämpfen dann müssen wir schauen was wir
machen können und ich gehe mal kurz raus
zum telefonieren
das ist endlich mal jemand der uns
verstanden hat oder ich das gefühl habe
er versteht uns und jemand der wie ich
das erste mal das gefühl habe er kämpft
mit uns und nicht gegen uns
ich bin hier in dir berg in brandenburg
zu besuch bei frau kirschner und vg hat
mir ihre geschichte erzählt sie hat
ihren partner verloren und möchte
eigentlich trauern aber hat jetzt doch
ein bisschen ärger mit der techniker
krankenkasse
weil es geht darum ja wirklich eine
mutter und kind kur zu bekommen und
deswegen rufe ich sie an
wie sehen sie den fall die mitarbeiterin
der krankenkasse möchte nicht
aufgenommen werden kann frank der noch
etwas für kathrin und ihre töchter
erreichen
ich habe jetzt gerade mit der
krankenkasse gesprochen hartes brot
nicht so einfach
das war ein sehr anstrengendes gespräch
ich habe aber erreicht dass sie sich aus
vier kliniken einer auskunft ja sie
können an die nordsee fahren wir
brauchen nicht an die ostsee
vielen dank das überraschende ist
wirklich und der erfolg ist das vg
schnell sich jetzt eine klinik aufsuchen
darf sie hatte bislang das angebot einer
klinik also eher eine neurodermitis
klinik die hält sie für ungeeignet und
war da so ein bisschen unzufrieden
aber wir haben jetzt erreicht dass sie
wirklich jetzt sich aus vier nordsee
kliniken eine aussuchen darf ja ich
freue mich natürlich riesig darüber
es ist einfach so dass ich denke das ist
auch mal zeit für mich und ich meine
zeit für mich du bist nicht um sachen zu
kümmern lediglich die mir eigentlich
nicht gehörten einfach mal zu sitzen am
strand ohne dass ich angst da muss ich
meinen kindern passiert beziehungsweise
ist sie gut aufgehoben sind ich wünsche
ihm wirklich alles gute wir haben in
kona sonst würde ich sie in den arm
nehmen vielen dank frank ochs es einsatz
war ein erfolg auf ganzer linie
wer das macht mich auch glücklich wir
konnten der familie helfen
ich habe die tränen gesehen die
freudentränen ich hab da strahlen
gesehen und so muss es ausgehend ich
wünsche der familie alles gute und damit
verabschieden wir uns heute von ihnen
bis zum nächsten mal bleiben sie gesund
ihr frank ochse